Hey, Donald Trump almost fell flat on his
face at a recent rally in Londonderry, New
Hampshire, again raising questions about Donald
Trump's balance and other supposed symptoms
that could connect to cognitive decline or
frontotemporal dementia or other conditions
that there.
There are discussions of Donald Trump having.
But even before we get to that, Donald Trump
is now just having rallies.
He's having rallies as if there is no pandemic.
He had 15 hundred or so people at his RNC
speech.
No masks, no testing, no social distancing.
And not only was the rhetoric of the RNC indicative
of a pandemic that's in the rearview mirror,
the actions were as well.
And Donald Trump now is simply resuming rallies,
large rallies, rallies without social distancing
and rallies, of course, with some arrests.
A number of different arrests taking place
after Donald Trump's Londonderry, New Hampshire
rally.
But first and foremost, so here is Donald
Trump walking up a set of stairs to give his
speech.
And as you can see, Donald Trump sort of losing
his balance and just narrowly avoiding falling
flat on his face.
And, of course, as people watch this, a lot
of speculation about Donald Trump's balance
and fitness.
We all remember Donald Trump being helped
down a ramp when he spoke at West Point just
a few months ago, speculation about cognitive
decline.
All of these questions continuing to run rampant
and certainly Donald Trump almost falling
down.
It certainly could be nothing.
I'll be the first to tell you.
It could just be a bad, bad set of circumstances,
taking a wrong step or whatever.
But certainly with everything else that's
been going on with Donald Trump bragging about
his great score on a cognitive test meant
only to identify very serious signs of cognitive
decline, dementia, et cetera.
Not particularly inspiring of confidence.
Now, once Trump got on the stage, it didn't
actually get any better.
Donald Trump ranting and raving about all
sorts of bizarre things.
Another one of these just humiliating events
that really is as much of an indictment of
the crowd who will clap for anything at this.
Point as much of an indictment of the supporters
as it is of Donald Trump.
Here is Donald Trump with a very strange rant
about protesting ass.
You're not mishearing me talking about his
ass.
This is the president.
Ladies and gentlemen, making no sense.
You know, I say protesters your ass.
I don't talk about my ass.
So this is an extremely low level of discourse.
It's a crowd that will cheer for anything.
I don't really like this term.
I think it's one of these stupid terms that
Trumpet's latched on to for a little while.
But the idea of the NPC, a non playable character
from a video game that just repeats the predictable
preprogramed actions, no matter what's going
on around them.
That's what I think of.
Thanks to Trumpet's who introduced me to the
term.
That's what I think of when I see people clapping
for anything that Donald Trump says.
Later in the rally, Donald Trump said people
have no choice but to vote for him and that
he really doesn't have to be running for president
anyway, I guess.
He is continuing to say that this is a favor
he's done the American people, I guess.
Take a look.
Every family and every neighborhood.
And we will fight for every vote we have to
win.
We have no choice.
Can I be honest with you?
We're working hard where I work, and I don't
have to do this.
I could get off that beautiful plane.
It used to be black and white with a red stripe.
That was Bob.
But that's Air Force One.
I get off that beautiful plane.
I could come up and say, ladies and gentlemen
of New Hampshire, you have no choice.
You have to vote for me, because if you don't,
you'll be put in radical lefties.
You'll have a depression.
Now, of course, remember, we have an economic
recession, depression now under Democrats.
These are just the facts.
We could debate how much they matter.
We can debate correlation versus causation.
But if you look historically under Democratic
presidents, stocks do better.
But stocks aren't really an indicator of the
economy at large.
Unemployment is lower under Democratic presidents.
GDP growth is higher under Democratic presidents.
Job creation is stronger under Democratic
presidents.
You can argue correctly that on too many issues,
there are not real substantive differences
between your average Democrat and your average
Republican.
That's a fair discussion to have.
But these numbers are clear.
So the fear mongering that the stock market
will implode if Joe Biden is president, that
the economy will implode, that you're Forell,
one case will be worth nothing, that unemployment
will explode, that taxes will quadruple.
None of it is borne out by the fact, by the
facts.
Another example, by the way, of how easily
the Trump crowd will just do whatever Trump
says.
Trump attacking or mentioning Chris Wallace
from Fox News.
The crowd booing they will at the drop of
a hat, turn on whoever.
Take a look at this.
One person, I think, was Chris Wallace.
Nice guy.
He's actually a nice guy.
He said that he didn't have the same energy
in the speech that he usually has, well, that's
a different part of his speech tonight.
I'm in New Hampshire and we can wing it.
So notice how Donald Trump's entire base.
I mean, for four years, Fox News was their
friend.
Fox News was their ally.
And mostly Fox News still carries water for
Donald Trump.
But notice how quickly the entire base turns
on whoever, including Fox News.
This is a sign of a cult that what the leader
says is not questioned and adhered to.
We spoke to cult expert Stephen Hassin a few
months ago, and it was one of the signs that
he talked about.
And then lastly, Donald Trump insisting that
the protesters aren't protesters and they
don't even know why they're protesting.
They're not protesters.
Those aren't drugs.
Those are anarchists.
They're agitators.
They're rioters.
They're looters.
They're not you know, you say that and some
of the people, not all of it, but some of
the people back there.
Oh, I do.
How dare you.
These are friendly protesters.
They're just looking for trouble.
Has nothing to do with George Floyd, has nothing
to do with anything.
They don't even know who George Floyd is.
They don't know George.
They have no idea.
If you ask him, who is George Floyd?
They couldn't even tell you.
These are just bad people.
Troublemakers.
And they shouldn't be representing our country
at important events.
And we've got to stop it.
So we're going to talk about the protests.
The inciting to violence of protesters by
the Trump administration in more detail later
on in the program.
But what you have here fundamentally is hostility
towards people exercising their rights under
the First Amendment in a way that Donald Trump
doesn't like.
That's what this is.
And I'm going to talk later.
I don't want to get ahead of myself of why
inciting them to violence is beneficial for
Donald Trump's reelection campaign.
That's coming up later.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show for more on this and
all of the other stories from today's show,